at the root of the mental health crisis
lie two more fundamental crises one
spiritual and one political sometimes
you'll hear people say i'm not religious
but i'm spiritual and very often what
that means is i'm not interested in god
or the truth but i am really interested
in me spiritually we no longer remember
what we are so we alternate between on
the one hand pretending that we're
purely physical meat puppet chemical
bags whose purpose is nothing but to
feel pleasure and to avoid pain because
our very existence is nothing but a
freak accident of nature that's on the
one hand on the other hand we pretend
that we're not physical at all that our
bodies have absolutely nothing to do
with our true selves our true self which
is entirely metaphysical such that some
guy's true and authentic self might
really be a little girl trapped inside a
hulking man's body obviously these two
views don't jive we go back and forth
between them sometimes within the same
conversations